which right there is click on that it is
just like buying anything else online
the choices here though could be deadly
assault rifles handguns pick what you
want and check out this is just one of
numerous completely legal websites
selling what are called ghost guns our
order for a Glock handgun arrived within
days well they send you in this box
through the post isn't legally
classified as a firearm but there is
everything in here to finish it and make
it one here in your own garage the frame
of the gun is encased in this jig with
markings telling you where to drill you
then remove a few bits of polymer and
insert a handful of small parts
including the trigger finish everything
right and you end up with a fully
functioning firearm within two hours and
perfectly legal for the personal use of
millions of Americans in the vaults of
the Federal Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
and Firearms some of the homemade
weapons they've recovered in one recent
raid in Hollywood they found dozens
being sold on the streets
anybody could purchase one of these on
the internet stores gun shows this is
not regulated the concern is that those
who can't legally possess a firearm like
those convicted of serious crimes can
simply make their own they have no
serial number
they are untraceable we have individuals
that are involved in making several
firearms and I'm getting engaged in a
business of selling those farms to
individuals who shouldn't have them and
those are individuals that are violent
gang members criminal organizations in
some of the most violent cities in the
country and when we see that
approximately thirty percent of the
farms were recovering in those
investigations are self-made it
definitely is a concern for us when a
gunman opened fire at a college in
California in 2013 he did so with an
illegal firearm he built with parts
ordered online he killed five people
I was shot four times and I think he got
somewhere in between 20 and 30 bullets
into the car
Deborah fine says those selling ghost
gun kits should take responsibility I
think that any company that's creating
parts for guns and and and selling guns
and you know not doing things that are
illegal with certain parts they can sell
still would want to make sure as much as
they could that they end up in the hands
of people who aren't going to do harm
with them the defenders of that right to
bear arms the spread of ghost guns like
the prospect of 3d printed guns is a
worry they can be a useful tool I think
to teach you know get people knowledge
and a new respect for you know firearms
and mechanics of them how they work you
know I think I think if if kept in its
original context I think they can be
good you know I think what happens in
some cases is you have criminals that
take the freedoms that the rest of us
Americans enjoy and twist them around
and use them for you know to further
their criminal agenda and that's that's
always a negative as for that handgun
you saw being made proof it was a
working gun we destroyed it immediately
after this one ghost gun gone but in a
country that wrestles with so many gun
questions who knows how many are out
there and in whose hands greg Milam
skynews